komm doch mal mit ja hat für euch
gestern auch geschneit
[Musik]
er hat gar nicht geschneit ist aber egal
meine lieben freunde denn wenn euch kalt
im flug
allerdings haben wir uns heute nicht
wegen meiner achsen geisteskrank
wunderschönen mütze versammelt sondern
will ich das wirklich machen follow me
round in london crafter um 24 06 2014
ich
reagiere heute auf meinen ersten block
ich habe gesehen dass zwei macs das vor
ein paar tagen gemacht hat von daher
dachte ich mir
ich habe war auch nie so gut da drin
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
hätten
[Musik]
was ist da falsch gelaufen
der klassische klamotten studien man
kennt ihn ja ihr habt richtig gehört ich
bin für einen tag morgens nach london
geflogen um 5 uhr und abends wieder
zurück geflogen um dümmste idee aller
zeiten
wenn wir da freundin gedacht hey so
richtig wird sie wenn wir einfach
morgens bei uns zuhause aufwache dann
wieder fällt es war einfach nur der
absolute stress wenn es euch gefällt
dass ich euch mitnehmen wenn ich neben
welche städte dass ich ein bisschen was
von den falls sie nicht von der stadt
allgemein mit krieg von im leben habe
ich nie wieder gerade
luca travel block gehen sie auf meinem
kanal muss dann halt einfach nicht wie
ich sagen viel spaß
[Musik]
die hatte jeder dreijährige und dachte
plötzlich er werde das ist marie mit mal
wie war ich im war ich im wir sind
gerade gelandet und der rundumblick
mitglieder sieht sowas ja wo ist marie
die war einfach nicht da hofft wieder
vergessen also in der stunde geflogen
von düsseldorf kommen wir auf jeden fall
wo ich schon machen so ein tagestrip und
ja scheiße auf klimaerwärmung gut ist
sechs jahre her da war das noch nicht so
in den köpfen verankert von wegen hier
muss man nicht unbedingt machen so ich
bin zum beispiel hat sich erst setzen
sondern war mit dem zug sogar
hingefahren wegen klima und weil diesmal
testen wollte und zwar richtig nice von
köln bin halt fünf stunden gefahren so
gefährt erst nach brüssel dann steigt
man da oben hat eine stunde umsteigezeit
dann von brüssel machen aber ich finds
geklagt wunsch
[Musik]
jetzt im zug nach london
ich will so schütze die mütze absätze
die wärmt ein wirklich viel zu krasser
mal wuchs die eigentliche gewinner von
wir haben einmal 3 und konnten uns alle
nicht richtig weiter helfen sie mir
einfach
ich sehe aus wie eine mischung aus einem
pinsel und klavier sitzt wirklich im
expressionistischen den normalen zug
aber dass wir uns das sagen so wenn
ihnen falsches ticket habt und die sind
schon drin sein was sagt so wir sind
jetzt hier in der victoria station die
sehr ich weiß habe ich außerdem sei es
alles gelb dieser sehr dass er wie
sicher ist also vielleicht anders es ist
natürlich bitter station ist sehr pompös
aber im vergleich zu wort lu station und
ich so groß war dass man dinge dass ich
immer meine nase
er hat mich verarscht als es schien
nicht die sonne und ich laufe mit
sonnenbrille rum
in der musik kommt so hat es wurde nico
beck und der szene situation spiele ich
einfach das video wurde
märz abgegeben der ausschnitt übrigens
warum mache ich da sind wir mit der nase
das wird jetzt mal der neue begrüßung
die laufen und james park gelangen
gleich zur westminster abbey
westminster abbey natürlich da gelangen
wir gleich hey ich habe mir erst drei
minuten von den zwölf minuten angeguckt
und ich kann jetzt schon nicht mehr
bürgern so ein paar dinge machen
[Musik]
sogenannte paar dinge machen was auch
irgendwie krasse ist so in deutschland
wenn du dich so films dann guckt mich
alle direkt an hier in england hat ihm
das einfach so
es war wirklich so in düsseldorf hat
sich nie getraut ich mir im blut haben
sie mit der kamera umlauf in london so
das hört sich so dumm an aber je mehr
leute um dich herum sind desto leichter
fällt es einem wenn man einfach nicht
auffällt aber zum beispiel wenn ich in
bielefeld herumlaufen würde mit meiner
kamera und ich würde mich belogen
eigentlich für denken
ich habe auch ein spaten übrigens um so
eine jacke
mega mega viele autos einfach
die leute hätten wir nicht gedacht denkt
man denkt man ja nicht big band eines
der 13 weltwunder
was wollte ich denn damit zeigen da sind
ja keine muskeln teufel gehen jetzt
gehen vor den bus sachen gibt die nicht
so
[Musik]
ich wünsche dem westerwald weil ja komm
doch mal mit
[Musik]
ich könnte das nicht mehr geben
ich hab mir damals aber auf mein erstes
video mit facetime reagiert das war zwar
auch quinta das war zwar auch ziemlich
komisch das ganze video das ist ja wie
im echten leben gedreht das ist ja nicht
ich vor der kamera sondern eine coole
doch dafür aber schon gute stücken oder
nein
wir sind immer noch in london jetzt
gesamte laufzeit
wer hätt's gedacht heißt er hatte
seitdem madrid jetzt angekommen lauft
zur folge
so misst der wahrheit gelaufen gerade
vom trafalgar square zum picken
ich weiß sogar ganz genau wo das ist und
man hier ist schon öfters hier ist dass
ich höre dass es genau hier kommt ihr
wieder mister weltweit raus genau in die
richtung bewegt aber
er hat mich denn verarscht
raffinierung
mit der sehr cooler laden muss man
wirklich sagen ist glaube ich zum
franchise ding in london aber die haben
diese kleinen diese san pellegrino
limonaden hatten die wahl mit
kohlensäure sind die gab es damals noch
nicht in deutschland solche sachen
münchen solln statt wo man freut sich
einfach richtig so
aber das sagt sogar getrunken san
pellegrino mit diesem orange sind wieso
er fand aber man fühlt sich gesund ich
mich dafür aber diese brille ich kann
die echt nicht mehr ich kann das ganze
video ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr sehen
ich glaube das ist ja auch gar nicht
spannend es mir passiert weil wir
fliegen am ende halten noch zurück und
ich quatsch noch ein bisschen nicht auf
video und der stadt jetzt auch beenden
wir lieben freunde wenn euch meine
reaktion auf meinen ersten block damals
in london gefallen hat das kann einen
daumen runter video abonniert main
kanals seien kein luxus sein und
schreibt mir doch mal und in die
kommentare ob ihr schon mal in london
watt und wenn ihr tipps braucht keine
sorge meldet euch einfach auf instagram
bei mister worldwide
[Musik]